[Music]
xinjiang where around 20 of the world's
cotton is produced is again in harvest
season hundreds of thousands of people
from ethnic minorities including the
uyghur community are being forced by the
Chinese authorities to pick cotton it's
estimated that nearly a million mostly
Muslim uyghurs are detained in camps in
the northwest region of xinjiang one
million ethnic uyghur Kazakh and other
Muslim minorities have been interned as
a counter-terrorism measure inmates have
been released have complained of torture
beatings and indoctrination in Chinese
Communist Party thought allegations that
China strongly rejects well you know the
thing that upsets me is you know there's
so much information but there's nothing
you can trust it's just been discovered
that xi'in the most profitable fast
fashion company in the world uses cotton
made with slave labor for their clothes
slave labor in China see China produces
20 percent of the cotton the global
cotton Market is estimated to be worth
over 46 billion dollars or of the
equivalent of 18 Beyonce's if you want
to think of it that way so you can
imagine just how important cotton is to
the Chinese government it's a source of
their wealth their power
the problem is farming is expensive you
have to pay thousands of workers a lot
of money for this hard labor a lot of
that money cuts into your profits but
lucky for you most of China's cotton is
grown in a little region called xinjiang
and what does xinjiang have
concentration camps of course Brands
spanking new concentration camps filled
with the ethnic Muslim minority called
uyghurs they're the ethnic minority that
originally lived in this region China
now calls xinjiang uyghurs are being
used as forced labor in the production
of cotton since 2017 up to a million
uyghurs have been placed in what some
call concentration camps and the Chinese
government calls vocational education
centers authorities in China's Northwest
are forcing hundreds of thousands of
ethnic minorities to work in the
Region's Cotton Fields over the years
uyghurs have been rounded up and thrown
into these re-education camps as the CCP
likes to call them we see 15 year old
children being detained or all the
elderly women like 73 year old woman
being detained there once they're locked
up these uyghurs are then subjected to a
lot of very bad things like literal
brainwashing when I got there more than
900 000 people had already been detained
for numerous Petty reasons like saying
something wrong we detained them on
orders from the superiors not on any
evidence when I asked them why and they
sat my family members think they might
have an intention to attend terrorist
activities
every day I had to make the prisoners
work I needed to make them say hundreds
of times thousands of times I am Chinese
I am proud of China
they tortured us they had cameras
everywhere you were not allowed to pause
scratch your head or cry if they saw
that they would force you onto a metal
chair they would make you sit there for
12 hours 24 hours you were tied to the
chair and if you tried to move it would
get tighter
then they make you repeat Chinese words
that you didn't know
if you forgot them they used an
electroshock device on your head
they don't see Ordinary People as human
beings they do things that you don't do
to human beings
you use various methods to put pressure
two people use sticks to weigh down
their legs tie him up and trample his
arm shackle their hands pour cold water
put a water pipe into his mouth and tie
him up and other unique favorite methods
there are numerous forms if accidents
occur it's normal that some people die
is
um
[Music]
and one of the bad things they're
subjected to is forced labor forced
labor in the form of things like working
on Cotton plantations we not only have
evidence of weaker forced labor and
Manufacturing in in in in garment making
we have evidence of a massive
state-sponsored OS labor scheme
involving hundreds of thousands over
half a million of ethnic minorities and
it's directly about the picking of terms
of Global Supply chains not as a game
changer it's really troubling is you
know they they call these uighur workers
batches you know they say they have 500
or 300 workers available to be hired in
15 days you know they can be delivered
within a week or two weeks and then they
can withstand hardship and they um and
you know they promise if you hire these
workers there will be no staff loss oh
yes a good chunk of cotton China
produces comes from Good Old slave labor
essentially really everything that we
purchase at this point is unfortunately
touched by this and these are serious
human rights crimes under international
law China's cotton coming from literal
slave plantations was a little
concerning so that's why in 2021 the
United States cracked down and banned
the import of cotton from the entire
xinjiang region one Senator called the
uyghur forced labor prevention act quote
the most important and impactful action
taken thus far by the United States to
hold the Chinese Communist Party
accountable for their use of slave labor
end quote and the rest of the world
isn't far behind but one company didn't
care about such Bands A company that
looked at just how Dirt Cheap this slave
cotton was and they just couldn't help
themselves one company called Shin yup
that she in everyone's always wondered
how she in is able to offer their
impossibly low prices on clothes well I
guess slave labor definitely helps and
Sheen's connection to slave labor is way
deeper than we could have ever imagined
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the slave cotton of Xi'an
[Music]
time
ready
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you know who else covers money power war
and crime our friends over at Epic TV
epic TV is a censorship free video
platform with original news programs and
documentaries investigating critical
issues not covered anywhere else and
you've gotta watch their brand new
documentary called The Final War which
exposes China's the 100-year plot to
defeat America in scary detail it
features General Robert Spalding who
we've had on the channel before and it
is great on top of award-winning
documentaries you get honest and
accurate news analysis and interviews on
events that major news outlets just
won't cover tune in to new programs
every day from Crossroads the Larry
Elder show Facts matter and American
thought leaders on Epic TV so if you're
looking for an honest and accurate news
source check them out right now we have
a special offer for our viewers just
sign up and start watching no credit
card required no strings attached if you
decide to subscribe within 14 days it's
just one dollar for two months so go to
watchepic.com Jake And subscribe that's
watch
e-p-o-ch.com slash Jake with the link
below thanks to epictv for sponsoring
this video
long ago Xi'an came out of nowhere and
suddenly dominated the world of fashion
e-commerce overnight they offered the
West these insane deals on clothes that
you just could never see from a
non-chinese-based company in one of the
main ways they blew up was through their
viral Xi'an Halls the one that uses its
own customers to be its biggest source
of free marketing within a decade Xi'an
became the number one fashion brand in
America and on their way to that pole
position in 150 other companies around
the globe too
people love Xi'an for their impossibly
low prices you can buy five pieces of
clothing and accessories for the same
price as one single thing at another
store most items cost less than 25
dollars a good amount of their small
jewelry costs less than a dollar that
cheap price tag attracts one really
important type of customer young girls
young girls that love splurging on
buying a lot of clothing in one go but
can't afford high prices
the problem is you can't sell anything
for that cheap unless you're making it
for next to nothing or nothing at all
preferably that's where the magic of
slave labor comes in for a long time
most people assumed that Xi'an probably
was producing their clothes in a sketchy
and unethical way but it wasn't until
just last month November of 2022 that it
was finally proven with cold hard
evidence that xi'an's clothes have links
to slave labor
foreign
[Music]
s before this video was being released
Bloomberg dropped the bombshell their
accusation was simple she and clothes
were coming from xinjiang and here's how
they exposed it first they ordered two
batches of clothes from Xi'an that were
randomly chosen out of sixty thousand
items that popped up when searching for
cotton on the website the first package
contained pants in a blouse and the
second had shorts and a dress to make
sure their findings weren't a one-off
fluke one package was ordered in March
and the other was ordered months later
in July then the Xi'an clothes were sent
off to a lab in Germany for analysis the
lab tested the items using something
called a stable isotope analysis it
measures the amount of carbon oxygen and
hydrogen and fabric to determine where
it came from these types of tests show
characteristics of the region where the
cotton was grown and and their results
are trusted around the globe isotope
testing has been used to verify the
origins of food wood and even used for
forensic evidence in court cases then
they compared the Xi'an clothing results
to two samples of fabric that definitely
came from the xinjiang region by doing
so they were able to see how similar or
different the isotope results were for
all samples
finally unveiled the truth the first
batch of Xi'an garments which included
pants and a blouse matched both xinjiang
region samples as the German lab CEO put
it quote we have to conclude it is a
typical sample from xinjiang China end
quote the second batch of clothes with
the shorts and dress had more variations
but the results still indicated that it
very likely came from xinjiang origin
and just like that the first concrete
piece of public evidence against Xi'an
was discovered but how were they doing
it the United States ban on xinjiang
Cotton was a huge deal so how was the
biggest clothing company selling in
America right now getting so much of
this stuff past the border right under
the noses of American authorities
foreign
[Music]
States announced its ban on Cotton from
labor camps in China most major fashion
brands started scrambling every company
from Amazon to Target was trying to
figure out how they were going to keep
making billions when they couldn't get
the cheap cotton they all relied on into
the us anymore it was a key part of
their supply chain but nobody wanted to
get outed as a brand who stuck to
Chinese slave labor to maintain their
profits which was happening left and
right since America enacted the cotton
van so everyone was trying desperately
to get xinjiang cotton out of their
clothes
amid all the chaos there was one company
that wasn't as panicked as their
competitors Xi'an as a Chinese company
whose selling point was ridiculously
cheap clothes you would think they would
be a little worried about these new
sanctions on the backbone of their
product but they had something that none
of the other companies did a loophole
unlike most fashion brands Xi'an
operates on an on-demand model where it
acquires products in small batches then
production increases based on demand and
it's all completely online Xi'an also
ships directly to customers from China
so when they're shipping clothing into
the US they're not giant shipments of
inventory to stores or Distributors
across the country no they're sending
each customer their 100 shopping spree
directly to their home nothing major
this is vital because the US Customs and
Border Protection only evaluate
shipments coming into the U.S that are
worth over eight hundred dollars that's
how it flies right under the radar
nobody is even checking their product so
why would she and stop they can get as
much slave made cotton into the U.S as
possible because of this neat little
loophole they've found
[Music]
oh
this isn't the first time that the
elusive Sheehan brand has been accused
of doing terrible things to achieve its
success previous investigations into
Xi'an and their supply chain have found
that workers in their factories were
working up to 18-hour days and were
given only one day off a month which
blatantly violates China's labor laws
she's been accused of stealing designs
selling clothes with high levels of
toxic chemicals and even mishandling
their customers information but this
time it's different it's not just an
accusation anymore it's backed up by
solid scientific evidence this is a
dangerous piece of clothing Xi'an the
biggest clothing retailer in America is
built off the back of slaves and the
great part is that the average U.S
consumer will hear how horrible this is
maybe they'll share it on their story on
Instagram and a week later they'll be
right back to ordering their next haul
from Xi'an
what's crazy is that imprisoning people
and forcing them to work in labor camps
is far from the only Shady thing that's
been happening in China recently the
country has been known to use their
citizens to make money in a myriad of
other ways one of those ways is forced
organ harvesting Yes you heard correctly
forced organ harvesting where China
forcibly harvests the organs of
prisoners to sell to desperate
foreigners in need of an organ
transplant but the story of what happens
in China's forced organ harvesting
program gets way darker than anything we
can share in a public video without
getting demonetized so instead we've
released it as a full-length documentary
available only for members of this
Channel all you have to do to access
this exclusive documentary and every
private video that's just too disturbing
for the public is click that join button
below and there's a refund policy too
unlike most YouTube memberships so if
you join and you don't think it's worth
it email us within your first month of
joining for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund so scroll down and click that
join button right now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you